six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty we've got time I think for
just a little bit more we'll go to the
702 area code caller from 702 who's this
and what's on your mind today your show
LJ are we are we on speakerphone right
now I'm sorry please please please take
us off speakerphone thank you okay
what's on your mind
I just have a question about also the
me2 movement is opposed to that there
seems to be a lot of focus on just the
perpetrators but I want to get your kind
of opinion on the people who are their
secretaries or the people that work with
those people should there be also a
focus on them as well to not only just
the people committed the crimes and you
know the sexual harassment but the
people who covered it up I think that
it's a fair question I think we want to
be conscientious and careful because
there may be the same power dynamics
that make it so that the direct victims
of sexual assault or harassment
sometimes don't come forward could
absolutely be at play with situations of
other individuals that are working with
the alleged perpetrator who might also
not be coming forward for the exact same
reason so I think you're bringing up
something that's perfectly fair and if
there is collusion or conspiracy to
cover up sexual assault or sexual
harassment we absolutely need to be
looking into who else might have been
aware however if we consider it valid to
say that a victim might not come forward
because of power dynamic stigma or fear
of repercussions then some third party
like an administrative assistant which
you're mentioning might also have not
come forward for the same reasons and I
think we need to treat it similarly
because the way I look at it and just
you know from my perspective of course I
never been in a situation like that but
I do feel that sometimes people take
advantage of a boss who is looking for
someone to cover up their misdeeds and
then also giving them you know power or
you know compensation for them you know
being completely sure I mean you're
bringing up scenarios where like an
administrative assistant has been paid
off not to talk about something that
they saw that's bad and yeah we should
do everything that we can in order
make sure that that comes to light but
if you're just generally speaking about
anybody who suspected or knew should be
punished as if they were perpetrators no
no they should actually be thought of
more as victims of the power dynamic
that exists there thanks very much for
the call I appreciate it and on that
note we were going to wrap up calls for
this week the first time of the year six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty is of course the number and it
will be the number the next time we take
calls as well